[Music]
[Applause]
chris collinsworth joins us chris before
we get to the important questions have
you heard
seton o'connor's impersonation of al
michaels it's very specific it doesn't
last long
i can't wait okay it started with lamar
jackson i think that's when seton first
picked up on it so seton your uh your al
michael's impersonation and there he
goes
that's it
that's it
well the problem is he did it to al and
then we think al is now changing his
delivery we're in his head and we feel
terrible because one of the great
announcers of all time and i think he's
thinking of my guy going and there he
goes
so we feel bad
can he do
you know do you do you believe in
miracles can we hear one of those one
time oh no we're i don't think we're
that talented i think you got to pay a
rights fee for that though chris but
you're probably yeah i think even i do
yeah
i i'll give him 20 bucks for me
um did you you stick them when you
played
um
a little bit a little bit i i tell you
though i watch these guys catch the ball
right now with these gloves and i'm
dying to try it i've never put them on i
mean i i they look like fly paper it
looks like you could stick your hand out
and just throw a ball and just have it
stick
have you tried them i've never tried
them yes and and there is that tackiness
there but it felt like stickum you you
would you couldn't miss a ball with
stikum but it was legal there for a
while was it legal when you were playing
for the bengals
um
kinda i don't think it really was but
everybody kind of did it you know lester
hayes was the the ultimate
guy with that but he would take the
stuff and like wipe it so it was like
goo all over you and one time in a game
i cut him
like the first play of the game and he
told me he was going to poke my eyes out
and i kind of started laughing not
because i was afraid of having my eyes
poked out as i just didn't want that
stick i'm like come on mandy can't put
that stick him in my eyebrow do
something else to me here wait he was
going to poke you and he said i'm going
to poke you in the eye if you do that
again
no he said i'm going to poke your eyes
yeah basically if you do it again so i
cut him and he's sort of laying on top
of me and
and and he's you know you know how it
goes and he kind of says i'm gonna poke
your eyes out if you do it again and i
just started laughing i just i couldn't
help myself i was like oh no not that
stick i'm in my eyes though was there a
defensive back though that made you
nervous
um
you know there were some really good
ones uh out there
mike haynes was a great player right he
was
um but as far as mel blunt maybe a
little bit because when i was first in
the league and i'd come up to the line
of scrimmage and i was pretty quick back
in the day you and i when we were
athletes we could we got a little
quickness to us
um
but you get across from mel blunt and
he's in that jam formation and he's six
four and his arms are like 18 feet long
and it takes you half an hour to run
around him he was a great player he
really was and but he never threatened
to poke my eyes out though he just he
was he just beat me to death
all the time did you see matt prater
last night he brought
melling salts onto the field to kick a
field goal
really are you
that's performance enhancing isn't right
before the snap he takes
two whiffs
of a smelling salt
a lot of those guys do that even on the
boundary and when they're out of bounds
i i i don't like that stuff right and i
i mean i've even i've seen announcers do
it i don't know what it does is it just
like wake you up yeah just like yes yes
it gives you a jolt it's a blast and
then you're like oh
whoa
but i
i did i've never seen that before where
a kicker comes out and and
takes a couple of blasts and then he uh
kicks the vehicle
i i think i've probably done it a few
times but i was unconscious
i didn't know i had no idea um this um
you know micah parsons lt comparison
i i'm hearing a little bit more chris
and i don't know is it is it fair
to make that
kind of leap
um
probably
not
lt was
a you know he was a hammer he was a big
strong
guy that changed everything in
protection it used to be that they
always sent the backs out to get the
outside linebacker
and lt changed that so we started
putting anthony munoz so i'm like forget
that we're not doing this traditional
stuff
and put him out there
micah parsons i would say is faster
and more athletic
and he doesn't even really play
pass rusher as much like if lt dropped
into coverage you were like thank god
you know they're good i'll take my
chances with them back there
uh where micah parsons really does do a
lot
in coverage you know he was 35 yards
down the field that game the other day
almost had one picked off so
i i i think they're different guys but i
think
is the potential there to have the kind
of career that he had
you know yeah i mean he's pretty flashy
if i said uh you could invest in the
rams or the cowboys the rest of the year
something tells me the cowboys offense
is going to wake up i i don't know
exactly what's going on
with with those guys and i think the
cowboys defenses
seems to be getting better and a little
healthier and
i i just i think there's a
i think there's a tad more upside
to the cowboys and it's going to be so
hard for the rams to just get out of
that division you know and get in a
decent spot i'm going to say the cowboys
any concerns with kyler murray with
arizona being an elite team are you all
in on arizona
not yet you know i think i think you got
to see him in a few of those moments i
think the prime time game last night was
was a uh was a good thing for them you
know for whatever reason they're not
winning games at home but
i thought you know kyler's a good player
he's going to be able to create and do a
lot of different things and i think
their defense is a little better than
what they showed last week giving up
some of those those big plays on on the
back end so
um i
i'm in on them am i quite as in on them
as i would be the bucks or the packers
not quite not yet
your level of concern with buffalo is
what
um
a little a little i mean that's that's
uh
that's pretty extended and you know the
whole thing now with with the patriots
um i mean that's demoralizing to have a
team go up there and throw the ball
three times and come out of there with a
win not you know not that there's
anything wrong with the buffalo bills
the thing i do like about him though is
i think that josh allen
will be able to throw it in any
condition so as it gets worse
that big body big hand you know kind of
guy i i could still see josh allen
coming up big in the playoffs i was
talking about the lack of candidates for
mvp this year
it just feels like it's tom brady just
because
nobody else has been that consistent and
with four four games to go would you
have anybody else above tom brady
no but i think rogers is right there i
think he could conceivably go on a
streak here uh you know as well so
uh it's
it just looks more and more like it's
gonna be
those two teams at some point doesn't it
i mean it was a championship game a year
ago you got the two hot quarterbacks
um so yeah i i
i if i had to pick favorites obviously
those would be the two favorites but
the thing that that i really like and
i'm just watching the tape of tampa bay
on defense
man they do a lot of stuff you you think
back to some of the fire zone blitzes
that pittsburgh used to do with dick
lebeau and some of those guys
um
they they can hit you with a lot of
different things and they they have no
problem at all with taking vitaveya and
then dominic and sue and dropping them
in coverage and sending both slot
corners off the edge they just they've
got depth now in the secondary they got
richard sherman playing free safety some
he got an interception
uh the other night so
there's a lot there
and when you go back to what happened
and how they won the super bowl last
year yeah they had a good day on offense
but they had a great day on defense and
and so i think as they're starting to
get that defensive side rolling both
them and the kansas city chiefs at this
point you know those are uh those are
two dangerous things talking to chris
collinsworth uh nbc sunday night
football analyst it'll be the buccaneers
against the saints coming up this sunday
night mike trico will be on the call
kickoff at 8 20. you know the saints
have tom brady's number since he's been
in tampa he beats everybody but he
doesn't beat the saints what does sean
payton do that nobody else is capable of
doing
you know i think the saints defense is a
little better um
and they they turned it over tom had a
fumble i want to say and two
interceptions
in that first game for them you know and
it was
back up quarterbacks jameis winston got
hurt in the game so it was it was an
unexpected win
for the saints so yeah
and we see it all the time with these
divisional games right it's just
weird stuff happens they know stuff
about each other that nobody else does
and i think sean payton may have a
little bit on tom brady we did the game
in tampa last year
and they beat them 38 to 3 something
like that i mean it was the worst game
we called all year because we just had
no idea
that you know everybody was going oh
yeah the box they're gonna they'll blow
them out and drew brees and company just
lit them on fire but when you go into
these production meetings and you
request certain people to talk to i
don't know if there are people who say
no i'm not going to talk to you
but all the time oh they do
of course yeah like
like for instance who would say no i
don't want to sit down and talk
just in general i mean some of these
guys they get asked every single week
and you know it's friday after practice
and they want to get out of there and if
they're
second in line or they got something to
do yeah we got the only ones who really
sort of have to do it i feel like are
the coaching quarterback
um they don't opt out but sometimes they
drive home like tom brady will talk to
us in the car on the way home
uh you know he sets up his phone and it
does you know it's it's
everybody's it's tech now and zoom it's
just exactly what we're doing here but
what are you allowed to ask like how
much can you get from brady
um it depends on what kind of mood he's
in
you know sometimes he's
literally fantastic
sometimes you know he gets mad at us
occasionally and then he's a little less
fantastic
but he's a deep
thoughtful
considerate guy you know the
the same guys that you would think of as
being smart or the same ones that are
the good interviews you know whether you
go
uh tom brady russell wilson aaron
rodgers peyton manning drew brees you
know you go right down the list the guys
that have been around and they know what
they can tell you and what they don't
tell you but a lot of times it comes
down to
do they think that you know
so if you ask the right question
and you prove to them that you've done
your homework and that you've studied
something specific you'll see them kind
of light up a little bit like oh okay
okay you got that all right you know we
were talking about that the other day
and a lot of times they'll expound upon
that and that's when it gets really cool
um
with um bill belichick one time i i
asked him something about
some remote
defensive end
and
and he goes yeah you know whatever and i
said well yeah i know he plays inside
and outside right he goes no no no you
know
bill no no no he just just plays outside
and and so we i go okay and so he goes
on with the interview and goes three or
four questions later
and he looked over at him and he went
he did play once now
[Laughter]
and i go yeah i said but you know i
wasn't gonna force my hand here and he
goes yeah yeah and he goes
what do you want to know and then he let
me start asking some questions
and he answered legitimately because he
knew
that i had done enough detail work that
he would now respond to some questions
and it's it's interesting at the give
and take
because
you do see
they they are unafraid to roll their
eyes at you if they are unimpressed with
the question and we've had like we've
had people walk out of the room i mean
you know is that different stuff
you know the brady
running he seems a little sensitive he's
like he's playing with it a little bit
but he's calling out peyton manning and
calling out tony romo like who do you
think you are
by making fun of my running ability or
lack thereof is that something that will
be brought up
when you talk to brady this week
oh hell yes i'm going to do it on the
air so he makes a video about me too
i come up with my own stick here oh man
this is the least athletic throwing
motion i've ever seen in my i'll come up
with something i don't know what i'm
going to do but yeah tom brady do a
video on me heck yeah man bring it on
but why is he running bruce arians was
mad at him like get your bleep on the
ground
did you watch it i mean yeah
and brady
a lot it was him
you kind of got the feeling he was the
one that was kind of stirring it up out
there got a quarterback sneak and then
you know there's no i know there's a
little shove and you know i'm like i go
he's either trying to send a message of
some kind
to this team but he came out of there
fired up after the first one where they
hit him he came right back with that
13-yard run and went flying down the
field maybe i'll go the other way maybe
i'll just go this is the greatest
running quarterback we've been since
michael vick and i'll get my own video
that'll be good i got bruce arians
coming up at the top of the hour give me
like an inside
question or jargon that i could use with
aryans that would go oh okay
what do you want to know
an insight you got to ask him about the
uh
the heart palpitation thing he's got on
his chest you know whatever that thing
is he's got some good answers for that
is um this whole thing okay the brady
stuff will be brilliant so what what do
i want you to ask him about
just so he thinks i've watched the all
22 that i've watched some film
yeah i haven't watched the offense yet
i've just been watching the defense so
far so i that's even better that's even
better that if i get something dude
the the pass protection i i think when
you watch the bucks right now
that they
that brady can stand and hold the ball
about as long as i've ever seen
in his career i mean he really looks
like he has
he has time back there to to make it
work and that that's thanks but the
other part of it was
the turnovers in the first in the first
game against the
you know the saints that was really
unusual
that that they turned it over like that
i don't think he helped me there i don't
i don't think he's good i didn't help
you much cause i haven't seen the tape
you want me to give you something on the
defense well you could have that you
know in dominican sioux and and vita
veil you know they they go back into
coverage and then you'll send the
corners
both slot blitzes coming out uh richard
sherman was in man coverage he was
holding on i'm writing this down
richard sherman had
knocks and man coverage across the field
and got the pick and so is he a safety
now is he a corner you know what is it
what do you see the future as here is
this is one of those
woodson kind of transitional shifts
you know you could be on this thing man
you could you could john all right okay
and if he doesn't like the question i'm
going to say yeah i shouldn't have
listened to collins one
so before just totally under the bus
absolutely
i've been moving under the bus
absolutely absolutely uh
have fun on sunday night great to talk
to you again my best to the family thank
you chris
thanks dan that's chris collinsworth